I don't know what's going on inside you
what are you feeling I mean obviously I
didn't think this was gonna happen like
this which means she would have just let
it keep going I've gotta talk to you
about
of course the Phaedrus situation can you
clear some of the rumors was she fired
um what I can tell you is that what you
have to look at is where she stands with
the group and when she left the reunion
she was on an island
none of the other women wanted anything
to do with her so that's something that
we'll look at as we figure out where to
go with the show you don't come for
someone's livelihood and their kids and
I think Phaedra was one of those not so
skilled cunning masterminds and it
exploded on her you know she was playing
with fireworks and in fact fire Andy
Cohen and Bethenny Frankel weighing in
on Phaedra Parks is a rumor to Real
Housewives exit at the 2017
nbc/universal up fronts in New York City
rumors are circulating that Phaedra is
blaming her else ting on producers
allegedly claiming they talked her into
spreading lies about co-star kandi
Burruss people are not told what to say
we cast very as you can ask Bethenny
Frankel yourself we cast women with
strong opinions and strong points of
view we can't force any of these women
if you've ever met a housewife you know
that we can't force them to say anything
but you just can't make you say
something and by the way if you're a
strong enough personality to be on one
of these shows then you can push back
but that's not how it really works they
don't always know what's going on and
they may go in a certain direction but
listen you're a grown woman it's all
about how it plays out in the group of
women that's what dictates everything
you